tell us what you do well I have the two
sides of a job I work as a tailor on
Saturdays as a like old school tale of
doing most of it by hand and doing all
the measurements just for one suit for
that specific person and my Monday to
Friday I work also in textile and
fashion but I do digital products now
I'm developing it but it's like like in
one I work in another year like a small
workshop and in the other one I'm like a
fabric in one person just using a
computer so it's interesting you have
one foot in the old traditional craft
world but your other foot is in the
future I think that's very wise tell me
what kind of suit you would make for me
what would you do well I I had I had
like the first time I I got the
wonderful news that I would have this
opportunity yeah I had like a meeting
with my master my master is the man that
is been teaching me the old ways yeah
and he would recommend because I know
the colors and the type of it but he he
would say like the type of fabric should
be a sea sucker because that's how I
think there is like an American
tradition yes yes once a year seersucker
suit yes and you wear it in summer my
master told me those things I didn't
know it's for the summer but I don't
know I think it's a it's something that
you should pick but my only guess I will
give you some color yes and you know
what color works for me I'm just going
to tell you right now blue I like a rich
blue because you know what I have
gorgeous beautiful blue eyes women look
into my eyes and they get lost I know
that yeah I know that usually not
related to me they're just having some
sort of a uh medical event but
um but you have a lot of blue why don't
you do like purple
um I would say green green Green would
work on you too okay maybe green all
right listen I will do uh you know about
my measurements yeah for leprechaun yeah
sort of not a leprechaun suit we're not
going to go down that route because I we
need to fight we need to fight those
stereotypes okay I'm sick of that no
leprechaun well you'd be a tall
leprechaun so you're fine no no no no
I've already it's bad enough that I walk
around with the Chile I probably should
and say things like you won't get my
gold no one gets me gold those are
things that I do that don't help but I
think adding a green suit to that would
be a mistake would you like my
measurements qualter are you awesome I'm
not around we're doing this
let's go let's do it let's do this okay
here we go are you ready are you ready
for uh
they just sent me I'm six feet four
inches tall uh my this is too many
measurements I just want like three
measurements and it's impossible look
what my guy just sent me neck full chest
right sleeve left sleeve bicep bicep I
don't have biceps wrist waist hips front
jacket length across shoulder back side
neck to shoulder inseam crotch
negative two Governor Brian needs a
friend is brought to you by T-Mobile
from listening to your favorite podcast
while driving cross country to listening
at home T-Mobile helps you stay
connected I wonder what people's
favorite podcast is oh I've got some
ideas that actually it's one idea yeah
you'll figure it out T-Mobile is
America's largest and fastest 5G Network
you can have seamless video calling oh
that's good streaming your favorite
podcast I'm not gonna say which one it
is yeah downloading apps games boy you
know what a gamer I am you're such a
gamer play starbursters yeah or realm of
Thanos
you can watch your favorite TV episodes
classic Conan new Conan old Conan
mid-season Conan as long as it's Conan
oh no find out more at t-mobile.com
Network fastest based on media and
overall combined 5G speeds according to
analysis by UCLA of speed test
intelligence data for q1 2023 c5g device
coverage and access details at
t-mobile.com
the simple measurements no they need
that for a bespoke suit don't you don't
you need all that stuff yeah all right
I'm gonna go fast and then you can uh
you don't have to write this down I'm
just gonna go really fast next 17 full
chest 43.5 right sleeve 35 left sleeve
35 bicep no no I lost it no no don't
worry it's you're gonna watch the
recording later on that was my point
okay okay remember this is all being and
then you're gonna you're gonna get your
whole family around and you're gonna
listen to this with the rest of Portugal
Jesus this is gonna be a national event
this is you just reading numbers bicep
14 wrist seven whole podcast 39.5 that's
around the one tips 41 front jacket
length 33 hips 41 Sea biscuits sea
biscuits hips 41. cross shoulders back
18 side neck to shoulder seven within
seam coming up fast Here Comes crotch
it's crotch insane crotch inseam crotch
in the lead it's crazy
15.5 that is down they just shot thigh
thigh has been put out of its misery and
crutch across the Finish Line That's the
money boys
oh my god did you get it Walter yeah you
don't have to make me a suit and um I uh
yeah it would be a pleasure wow your
measurements Portuguese way yeah we'll
do it the Portuguese way what's the
Portuguese way centimeters
I thought it was like different way of
groping or something no what they do is
they dip you they dip you into a tank of
port and then they see how much time how
much Port you displace and then they
build the suit no it's it's a really
nice it's like the first time you have
like you usually when uh when we do the
suits the first time is the talk like
talking about Fabrics what is the
ceremony what is the situation if we are
single or it's going to be with somebody
else
and it's it's a really nice in your case
it's like you are very familiar for
everyone in the world
so wouldn't be that like intimate in the
say but usually it's like one of the
most intimate things that the men being
with another man do usually usually are
you saying that you measuring me would
be one of the most intimate things that
two men do together is that what you're
saying usually when you go to a tale in
an old school one it's like happy all
traditional ways yes being together in
the same place I'm not very traditional
though but no no but what you're saying
is I would be uh what be wearing you
know boxer briefs but that's about it
and you would be taking it in a shirt no
time no shirt no shirt no please he's
saying you need to work no he's gonna be
a shirt but anyway I'm gonna be wearing
um pretty much a thong and uh and and
it's just gonna be the two of us what's
the problem is that an image you don't
like are you gonna be oiled up and stuff
well I think oil doesn't hurt it does
does it does not help clog no well he's
not putting the cloth I mean he's just
taking simple measurements and that
helps the uh measuring tape slide Across
the Skin
kind of like a whip hey what's happening
I I just blacked out what happened
we somehow is there a way that you could
just could you be canceled could you be
whipping me with oh my god
with the measuring tape and I should be
restricted I think I should be
restrained in some way
so that the measurements are precise and
in the end do you even want a suit oh I
didn't even think okay who's making a
suit I'm just curious It's someone
making a suit no now why is there a ball
in my mouth oh my God the jaw the
distance from Top jaw to bottom jar
right yeah
that's right
why are we doing this in the basement
later on I never got that suit but God
that qualter and I had a good time